it's the very last Friday afternoon
session and we're all getting tired so a
very apt topic is that you know such a
time of the day and week couldn't we
just somehow
uh stop working ourselves and dump all
these complicated work we're having on
proving our theorems on on the computers
instead and as it happens this is
exactly what Suzanne was going to talk
about
uh how to automate the proof search so
please
right
so that's exactly the first slide um can
we actually can a machine actually
substitute us
um so so I wanted to start with uh
the first reference that I've heard of
this proof search problem which was this
letter uh from girl to Panama
and and he starts saying
um I would like to allow myself to write
you about a mathematical problem which
of your opinion would very much interest
me one can obviously easily construct a
turing machine which for every Formula F
in first order predicate logic and every
natural number n allows one to decide if
there is a proof of f of length m okay
um so he defines this uh function uh PSI
F of n let it be the number of steps the
machine requires for this
and now let's look at the maximum over
any Formula F
the question is how fast this formula
Phi of n grows for an optimal machine
and then he says one can show that Pi of
n is greater or equal to K times n the
proof is not on the letter but this is
this we can do
um if there really were a machine that
could run in this uh constant time zone
or even constant times N squared so I
guess this was his notion of uh feasible
or efficient machine uh this would have
consequences of greatest importance
namely it would obviously mean that in
spite of the decidability of the inside
looks problem the mental work of a
mathematician concerning yes or no
questions could be completely replaced
by a machine
after all one would simply have to
choose the natural number and so large
that when the machine does not deliver a
result it makes no sense to think more
about the problem
um yeah so this is the question uh we're
considering is it uh is it possible that
a machine actually runs efficiently to
find proofs
okay so what we'll be considering is uh
we have a CNF formula we want a machine
that is going to stay sat or unset and
also not only say Saturday or inside but
output some proof of that which can be
either a satisfying assignment or a
refutation a proof of unsatisfiability
um and clearly the running time of The
Machine it has to at least read the
input and produce the output so it's at
least the size of the input plus the
size of the output and we'll focus on on
sat here which is the most interesting
case because here we have a very
um short certificates
and this is so Tony talked about this
already
um uh so the question is for example
like if what if F has a refutational
polynomial size can I find it in
polynomial time
um and even can I do anything better
than the trivial uh truth table
refutation
um and the well since the problem is nnp
if we're going to show any kind of
impossibility result any kind of barrier
it will at least have the Assumption P
naught equal 10 P because if P equals
and P that P equals MP then I can solve
this and follow them at a time
okay so this is what I uh plan to do for
for the talk
um so Tony already talked about uh proof
systems but I'll just go over some
example of proof systems and algorithms
that search for proofs in these proof
systems uh then I'll actually talk like
theoretically about the problem like
what are known non-trivial algorithms
and what are the known barriers
um after that I'll try to give a more
historical uh View and and then well if
there's time I'll talk about some ideas
behind the proofs but I'd like to talk
about some other also related questions
okay so some example of proof systems
well we saw this uh already recently
well we have a tree like resolution and
there's an algorithm it's called dpll
which is essentially uh searching for
tree-like Resolutions by considering
this uh this search problem so querying
variables and
um backtracking whenever a falsified
Clause is found so this this was
implemented in the
um when was it early 60s
and then there's there's another class
of algorithm cdcl which is actually
searching for resolution proofs and
there you're actually learning Clauses
so the dag that you get is actually uh
the yeah it's not a tree it's actually a
dag so the the cdcl algorithms actually
find resolution
uh refutations
um okay then uh another way of searching
for reputation so Tony also talked about
yeah we can translate uh causes to
linear inequalities
um and
uh and then we can just do some integer
linear programming we'll do we can do
linear combination of inequalities and
we can do some kind of integer reasoning
so there are different kinds of uh
integer reasonings but for example uh
here
um I can if I know that 2x plus 2i is
greater or equal to 1 I can drive that
well if I'm over the integers X Plus Y
is greater or equal to one
so uh yeah this Cur there are also
algorithms that are searching for proofs
of this type
um and and the goal is to show that
there's no integer feasible solution
so this would be uh algorithm searching
for cutting planes type proofs
then there are some the algebraic and
semi-algebraic group systems so now we
translate the Clause into a polynomial
and we also include these Boolean
constraints
and
um and the set of these constraints is
going to be unsatisfiable uh if if and
only if there's no common root so here
we have a Hilbert to the student tax and
we have grubner-bases computations which
corresponds to the polynomial calculus
proof system
um so it won't really matter what the
definition here is just remember we're
working with polynomial equations that's
that's what matters
uh then we have the semi-algebraic proof
systems
um and here the idea is that uh so the
way I'm defining it here I still have a
polynomial equations and I'd like to say
that this these are unsatisfiable if the
sum of these polynomial equations is
strictly greater than zero
because if there were satisfying
assignment if I would plug that in to
all the constraints I would get exactly
zero so if I can show that this is
strictly positive I mean every every
constraint is uh is either zero or one
when they evaluate it on zero one input
so if I can show that this function
corresponds to a strictly positive
function then I'm showing that this is
unsatisfiable
and now we can think okay how can I
actually synthetically prove that sum of
coefficients is strictly positive and
there are different ways of doing this
um so this is uh perhaps not the
standard definition you would find but
it's equivalent and I think it's a nice
way of thinking of these proof systems
so so you would like to say that the sum
of the constraints equal some positive
Epsilon
plus something that is not negative
and what this non-negative function is
uh we'll Define these different proof
systems so for sure Ali Adams this
non-negative function will be just a sum
of these generalized monomials which are
just like these constraints which
evaluate to either zero or one
um depending on what you plug in but
they're always positive
so this this non-negative function will
just be a sum of such constraints
so if I can prove that the sum of my CI
is equals for some uh PX of these
Epsilon Plus
um this non-negative function then I'm
showing that it's unsatisfied
does that make sense
um another
uh possibility would be that this PX is
actually a sum of squares so that's also
a non-negative function so if I could
write sum of CI equals to some Epsilon
plus a sum of squares I would also be
showing that it's unsatisfiable and that
corresponds to the sum of squares proof
system
so
um yeah so these are
possible uh algorithms that search for
proofs and different proof systems
and it yeah again it won't really matter
exactly what this proof system is this
group systems are we can think just of
yeah we have here we're dealing with
Clauses here I'm dealing with linear
inequalities polynomial equations here I
actually have polynomial equations and
inequalities over the wheels
um and there as uh Tony mentioned
there's this hierarchy among the the
proof systems I actually have the errors
in the opposite direction as Tony
um but yeah but you have some so higher
up is or the more powerful proof system
that shorter proofs
okay
many questions here
so uh let's look at some of the
um uh algorithms and barriers that we
have for the different proof systems
uh so just to uh so Tony also gave the
definition of automatability but I'll uh
repeat it so we have some uh proof
system s and we say it's automatable if
there exists this algorithm that
deterministic algorithm that will
produce a refutation in this proof
system and it will run in time
polynomial on the input plus the
shortest possible output it could
produce
so it as we mentioned before the best
possible running time is it has to at
least read the input and uh produce some
proof and this is the shortest possible
proof and we're asking for polynomial in
this
so this would be uh automatability and
then we can also Define
automatable in time some f of n if I
allowed the algorithm to run so for
quasi polynomial or some sub-exponential
time
so the first uh results over tree-like
resolution so very simple group system
um suppose there's a proof of polynomial
size can I do can I find it in
polynomial time can I find it in
anything better than 2 to the end
um and this is a result from being
potassium from 96 that yes we can do
better than today and not polynomial but
we can do quasi-polynomial
and this is a very simple algorithm so I
want to show you
um
yeah so this is
quasi polynomial in in estimate
so uh to show this I think it's easier
to think of the decision tree so this is
equivalent so let's think of the the
decision tree and basically we just have
to figure out what variable we have to
query first
um and we know that one of the sides of
the decision tree is going to be of uh
of size uh at least half of the size of
the toll of the whole decision tree so
uh we will just recurse on that
so let's start supposing I know the size
of the smallest proof okay so suppose I
know it's uh some s and now uh I know
that there will be one one of the sides
is going to be of uh size s over two
um so I'll just try all possible
variables they're n variables and I'll
try all possible assignments to that
those n variables so I have 2 times n
and I'll call recursively that's the
same algorithm with one less variable
and with this size
half
for One Direction and for the other well
I also decreased the number of variables
but I can't say anything about size so I
just call it again with the same
parameter s
so if I just solve this recursion I get
that the running time is going to be
angular logos
um and the fact that I don't know s to
start with is not a problem because I
can just run this for S equals one two
three until I actually get a reputation
so just out of that dress there
okay so this is
um
a quasi polynomial uh algorithm
automating tree like resolution and then
well we can ask can can we do better
than this can we do it in polynomial
time
um and actually well we have uh one
barrier for this if we could do better
than each H would be false
so
um what do we know is that if I yeah I
could do uh enter the log one minus
Epsilon s eth is false even if I could
do n to the little Vlog s then the
randomized version of each key it should
be false so there is some kind of
barrier I can't improve on that
algorithm
so this is kind of like the ideal result
we would like we would like some
automatability algorithm and then show
that this is typed
uh okay
so yeah please interrupt me yeah there
are any questions
so for resolution
um the best automate ability uh
algorithm we have runs in uh Time end to
the square roots and log s
so this is better than to to the end
which would be the trivial when say yes
is polynomial in N or this is small but
it's yeah it's not as uh as good as for
a tree like resolution
and the way this algorithm goes is well
uh I can find refutations
in time and to the W where W is the
smallest uh the narrowest uh width I
need for the refutation
so this I can just look at all possible
causes of size W there and to the O of w
of these and uh and I I'll just try to
see what which of these causes I can
actually derive and if I can derive the
empty Clause Then I then I know there is
a proof of I can find the proof uh in
with W of size and to the W
so the way I get this automatability
result is uh is using Benson victorson
there's a classical
um
relation between size and width so
um they showed if there is a size s
refutation then there is a width square
roots and log s refutation
so using uh this this relation is how I
can get to that
that running time
so again foreign
yes yes yeah good
so the formulas we start with I had
bonded with
so we can ask again can we can we do
better than this can we do like positive
polynomial like we do for tree-like
resolution
and
the first answer uh to this is well not
via width because this is
um pretty tight for for resolution so
there are uh formulas that have
polynomial size refutations but that
require uh large width so I can't expect
to using this this kind of argument to
get a better
um
better automating algorithm
but I can still ask okay is there
another kind of algorithm can I can I do
better
and
um and this is this result from a few
years ago about serious uh actually
showing uh tight
um non-automatibility results so if I
could automate resolution in polynomial
time then and P equals p in causing
polynomial times and then p is in QP and
even in sub-exponential time
so this is yeah pretty tight because
it's in uh if and only F here
okay so again yeah we have a uh
we understand the automatability of
resolution now
um pretty well
and then okay yes
is tight under ETA
um
[Music]
um I I think you can get this by
modifying outside
um a little bit so you have to be a
little bit smarter with like how you
can't have these player things so I
think it's doable and it's not hard
um but it hasn't been written up
we're just like with uh W type
General
yes yes yeah I didn't write that yeah
there are really formulas that uh can be
done with w and that have seism
sorry first question sorry
um so here we have an uh algorithm that
finds that automate resolution in this
time and the question is is this
algorithm the best possible
and and I think modifying outside
you can get that it's that this is
pretty much maybe you lose some log
factors but other than that I think you
get
under eth that this is
so yeah so we can ask the same questions
for cutting planes
[Music]
um
and actually here we don't know any
automating algorithm
so anything that does anything better
than two to the end even if there's a
polynomial size proof
but we have the same barriers as for
resolution
so this was a generalization of what
city is Mulan
um
yeah but it's still there's still
interesting open questions here
foreign
and then we have the semi-algebraic
proof systems
um and here
um it's
in some cases here we have as as for
resolution uh degree D repetitions can
be found in time activity
and this is true for a new student sets
for polynomial calculus over finite
fields for sure Ali atoms and sum up
squares under some uh conditions it's
also true
so
um so this is part of what we need for
an automating algorithm but then we also
need a relation between degree and size
because this would be degree
automatability if we're talking about
size automatability we want
um uh this this relation between size
and degree and this we have for
polynomial calculus pressure all the
items and for sum of squares
so that means that uh we get this same
kind of automatability for polynomial
calculus over uh finite fields for as we
the same one as we have for resolution
and for sure all the items and uh under
some conditions also for some squares
um
foreign stats we still have the degree
automate ability but we don't have the
size automate ability because we don't
this relation does not hold for for new
students that's so there are some uh
formulas that actually require large
degree in those students but have very
small proofs
so
um so yeah it's also open whether there
is some kind of automating algorithm for
those two insights so this this is not
known uh with regards to size
foreign
of barriers we also have this for
polynomial calculus and no students that
we have the same barriers as we have for
resolution
okay and for sum of squares and Charlie
items we don't have any
for SOS I think in algebraic systems
answer them
if you know in advance okay
[Music]
okay so you don't you don't know
um
quotations you know the monomials and
then you can search for the position is
that right
I wonder how it works in some of squares
for because then you would do degree
automatability maybe there's some catch
there
yeah yeah
maybe there's a caveat that I don't
know
yeah so yeah there's some issues with
with politicians here but um if they
have small coefficients
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so here are some
system
what about IPS is there anything
[Music]
well there is based on a limitability
results
because this uh this is actually a weak
automatability and then it's monotone so
it's for anything that stimulates these
proof systems
uh but in terms of automated ability I
think so
for these spreading systems
um
there was a result of project and
putlock 98 showing that extended frege
is not automatable unless RSA can be
broken by polynomial size circuits
um and actually yes
can Define such proof systems that are
not I mean in some sense like I guess
bonded degree like bonded with
resolution and Boundary polynomial
campus would actually be examples of
This research completely jumping up and
down right notice tell us that it's like
hard and then you sort of go to in some
sort of boundary degree bounded with
resolution and it becomes sort of easier
well you could somehow fix it and say
like either on the grid or else I have
to fall back to treat my question
okay okay
so this sort of zigzagging that proof
search is hard and then for a slightly
stronger system gets easier then it gets
hard again when you go to Fuller
resolution
it's not just I guess a theoretical
possibility
you have to find it a little bit careful
yeah
um
foreign
automate ability in in this paper what
they mentioned is feasible interpolation
uh but
um automatability implies feasible
interpolation as Tony was saying any and
even I'll talk about this later later
even weak automatability applies to some
interpolation
um and this was later generalized uh in
uh in two papers for
um tc0 frege and and everything that
stimulates it uh so that it's not
automatable unless the DP Hellman
procedure can be broken by small
circuits so polynomial size for tc0 and
sub exponential size for ac0.
[Music]
um
so these are the the results and I just
wanted to give like a taste of how this
is proven because it's actually like the
idea is very simple
um so first uh we say that a proof
system has this feasible interpolation
property if uh sure if there is a short
refutation of this kind of split uh
formula then there is a small circuit
that that interpolates this but given
said outputs whether a or b is upset
okay
um so we'll actually use the this
definition of feasible interpolation so
the idea of the proof is I'm going to
get some function which I uh is my
assumption that it's this function is
hard so some function uh that is
injective and is hard to invert
uh and I'll write this formula encoding
that the last bit so here I have some uh
inputs the last bit is zero that equals
z and if the last bit is one also it
also equals that
and um yeah since since f is injective
this is an unsatisfiable formula
so now suppose the proof system has uh
if we can show that the proof system has
a short refutation of this so if the
proof system is strong enough
um so if we can let's say tc0 we can
show that it has a small proof of this
then if tc0 were to have feasible
interpolation then that would mean that
I can actually say which of these two is
unset which means that I can actually
ident figure out what is the last bit so
I'm I can invert the function
so so this was so if I assume the
function is hard to invert then the
proof system cannot have feasible
interpolation
so that's the the spirit of all of these
uh proofs yeah
yes because I need to make sure that I
can prove this upper bound
yeah in in the proof system
so I find this like an interesting time
of not automatability because it really
it depends on proving
some upper bound
that's why it only holds for these
strong Roof Systems
okay so here is a little summary of the
uh non-automatability results and here
we have things in between
um and here's some other things for
which we don't have any
non-automatibility results
so just a little bit of the historical
perspective so here's a timeline of uh
many of the results regarding
automatability and this is mostly to
point out so the pink ones are of
positive results so algorithms and these
are
um non-automatability results so there
was a lot of work going on
um from mid 90s to early 2000s
um then there was more or less a gap
um and then after at cydia's mother
there were many uh follow-up results
so I'll mention a few of these
um so some of the early results so uh uh
bus and ivama had independently showed
these results so let's show that
um determining if a propositional proof
system has a proof of size s is NP
complete for certain phrase systems and
if I must show this for resolution up to
some additive polynomial
um and then there was a result of soon
after showing that the uh to approximate
the length of the shortest proof within
a linear Factor was hard for several
proof systems
uh yeah Tony mentioned this too
uh and then was the question well yeah
what about what about polynomial
uh so regarding resolution uh this uh so
we're shown yeah we can't
um automated linear time MSP equals MP
uh then uh electronic and resverov had
we can't automate in polynomial time
unless WP equals fpt
and this actually also applied for to
three like resolution
um and they left open uh the question
whether is resolution uh quasi
automatable
then there was uh almost simultaneously
with with that said yes Mula uh showing
some uh something better than polynomial
uh non-automatibility unless eth is
false and then finally yeah our city has
moved actually answering the question
completely this was more or less the
story for resolution
and
um and then some of the follow-up
results so they will follow it results
on uh Alexa Vikram showing the same
thing for the students as a polynomial
calculus
and then building on that city as
Mueller there were several
um and I think this says something also
about how yeah this this proof was more
easily generalizable uh
through other proof systems
so yeah I'll try to sketch some ideas
uh behind the proof and then also you
have mentioned some related questions
uh so yeah one uh principle that Tony
also mentioned is the reflection
principle so the idea is yeah I want to
encode if a sentence is provable then it
is true
so the unsat version is saying that uh
well there is a satisfying assignment to
the formula
and there is a reputation of the formula
okay so this is a unsat formula and here
I'm saying that there's so Pi is a
refutation of f in size s
and n is for the number of variables in
it
um yeah there exists F of size M which
has a key refutation Pi of size s and
has a satisfying assignment of
um and
just the other name for this in case
you've seen as the refutation principle
or reputation
um of that but it's the the same thing
except I'm yeah I'll fix some f but this
I'll get back to this
uh and the idea I guess uh what this is
capturing is uh how hard is it to prove
lower bounds for uh for a proof system
yes
but do you want the negation in front of
them
uh yeah this is just
uh but there's a proof it claims that
there exists that there exists uh proof
yeah I guess this is just to say that
there is a a refutation because that's
what I want to say
foreign
foreign
was that if if we take an F which is
actually satisfiable
and states that there there is a
refutation of f which is not true if
that's satisfiable of size s
then there is a polynomial size
refutation of this so this is a false
statement saying that a satisfiable
formula has a small refutation
so this unsaid formula
can be refuted in polynomial size
uh so this is the reflection principle
which is going to be uh useful for
proving non-automatability
so yes whether acco
so then you say like
it like plug in
a formula which is hard for resolution
and no one line about
yes yeah so I will plug in a CNF formula
that actually is hard for resolution and
we give a size budget that is to stingy
and now it faces your prayer really
understood resolution
like a short ac0 phrase refutation of
this meta formula claiming that there is
a short resolution
okay
so so what's the weakest blue system
that can prove resolution lower bounds
is there a Friday
I think there's a norm
by uh
so it's extended I don't know if it
reduces it
maybe yeah
okay maybe yeah maybe I'm wrong
but like extended yes
uh there is a cabinet here that people
that ignored it's the uh the measure of
the lower bounds
which is strong from the top for a
slightly lower level
yes that's
um
okay so yeah so the the
overall idea of City at Mulan so
actually they have this this is their
main theorem which is the one that
implies that
um so the idea is that uh given a
formula f
we want to produce another formula
um in polynomial time
um such that if f is satisfiable
AFF has small resolution refutations
and if f is unsatisfiable a of f does
requires exponential size resolution
refutations
so this is this is the the main theorem
that acidius Miller needs
and and let's just see how that that
implies
um the non-automatibility so yes suppose
suppose we have an algorithm that
automates resolution in some some time
let's think polynomial for now so we're
proving the first point polynomial and
then
um
then uh we would like to decide whether
this formula is Saturn on Sat by using
this algorithm
and polynomial time let's say
so uh
I can just run my automated ability
algorithm on this formula here
for enough steps so that if it if it
actually uh
if it actually outputs a refutation it
means that F must have been sat because
uh if there's no small refutation
so that's it if if it's a facet since
I'm running it for enough number of
steps it will output a refutation and if
it does return the reputation it must
mean that f is that because I did not
allow it to run in it's enough steps so
that it could output this large
refutation
okay
so so as as long as I can construct in
polynomial time a formula that has this
kind of Separation then then I'm done
then I can prove the non-automatability
of resolution
so that the idea for for uh proving this
I can okay this is a simplified version
simply choose this formula a of that to
be the the refutation formula so the
formula saying that uh F has a small res
resolution refutation
um so the first part I already have from
putlock that if if f is satisfiable then
this has polynomial size resolution
refutation
uh and uh yeah the idea we'll use if
that's satisfiable there is a satisfying
assignment and somehow I can use this to
find an invalid step in this purported
refutation okay so that's the idea of
the upper balance
um
and then now we need to also prove the
lower bound when f is unsat
um and here's one way of doing it well
there are many encodings for this one
possible encoding will have S times n
variables and log n with
okay so it will use some kind of
pointers for encoding this but the idea
is to show that this requires large
width so to prove a width lower bound
um and and this can be done by some
wrote it here this yeah can be done by
some reduction to pigeonhole principle
and then once I have this I can simply
apply the size width relation from uh
Memphis and victorson and conclude that
it must have
uh it must require some large size
and then I can just choose the parameter
as large enough so that this is actually
two to the n
so the lower bounds would consist of
proving the width lower bound and then
we could use bentos on pictures
and
um yeah and this with lower bound one
way of doing that is by uh reduction uh
from digital prints
there's also this is not how a city is
Muller this last step uh is not how they
do it
um
so they do prove a width but then they
use some kind of lifting to get the
lower bound and this is somewhat of a
more robust proof and it's easier to
generalize
so the lifting that still preserves the
upper bound
um and and then you uh you can show that
you have this um that you can get a
lower Bound for for resolution by this
by this lifting and then just
generalizations of this lifting you can
get lower bounds for the different proof
systems so it's basically it's the same
formula we just change what kind of
lifting uh we have to use to get the
lower bones
by general idea
yes
we don't have barriers yes
[Music]
um
for
or because we don't have the width lower
bound the degree lower bound so for
example for sure all the atoms we could
have a lifting theorem but we can't we
don't know how to prove this the degree
we're about
yeah so and for for that the so one way
of putting the degree lower upon this
via this reduction uh digital principle
but this instance the fictional
principle is easy for Australia
so you can't get it through that so
there might be another way of proving
the degree lower bounds and then and
then you would guess realistic
yes
yes so it is uh some kind of weak
automate ability it's not the full
recoverability but it's
and it's immediate first yeah
[Music]
so just to say something about weak
underneathability so we share proof
system is weak automatable if there is
an algorithm that will return some Q
reputation but it's allows it's allowed
to run the time polynomial on the
shortest P reputation so it can return a
reputation in a much stronger proof
system
um and allow to run or along for more
time yeah
um and then there's some relations so
what do we some of the things we know
about uh weak automatability so that
that economical pair and prepare the um
there is a satisfying assignment that
there is a limitation uh is uh
polynomial separable if and only if the
proof system is weakly on the main level
um this is what Tony said if the proof
system is strong enough that it can
prove its own soundness then weak
automatability is the same thing is
happening principle interpolation
foreign
uh but it was also shown that this
parody game can actually there's a
positive
so yeah so this is not
um
not such a strong uh reason to believe
that resolution is
um
is enough because then you can prove uh
Summits right is that I think so yeah
this is bullet two a reason to believe
um under cryptographic conjunctions that
proof systems that are strong enough to
prove their own soundness are not weekly
automatable
yes okay yes that's exactly yeah so the
uh when we the non-not availability that
we had for for stronger perceptions were
all non-weekly out of universities
Okay so
going back to Chicago I'd like to
um uh yeah so
uh she says that's
um yeah when he's talking about
automating uh if if we could do it in
um this amount of time that would mean
that the number of steps as opposed to
trial and error can be reduced from uh n
to log n right so the trial and meta
error would be this here n is like
exponential in Middle n so can be
reduced from two to the end to some
um
let's say paulian
uh and then later on he says well it
would be interesting to know how
strongly in general the number of Step
steps and finite combinatorial problems
can be reduced with respect to simple
exhaustive search
um yeah so uh the automatability
questions that we've been seeing haven't
exactly yeah they've been addressing
this but we haven't answered how much
can we actually reduce if I want to find
the proof of size S I know I can do it
in time 2 to the s
how much better can I do to find this
proof so yeah can we do can we do any
better
and and trying to
um
somehow formalize this
um I I was bold enough to
um write oh yeah so this is kind uh yeah
can we can is it the case that finding
short proofs can require more time than
finding long ones so this is also what
Tony said so I can definitely find the
proof and type 2 to the end but if I
want to find one of size two to the S
um I can I do any better than than to
the S yeah so this so this was uh yeah
perhaps too bold but I wrote this uh
minimum proof size problem
uh which I tried to make as similar as
possible to the mcsp problem and uh so
here I'm given the parameter s and I'm
given the trivial proof let's say that
the true table proof of size uh two to
the end
and and my goal is to Output is there a
proof of Silence
can I do this in
uh time poly and S plus two to the end
uh and I think there's no
um nothing known with regards to this
and I don't know if there's any relation
to mcsb
um
so I don't know maybe something yes
but it's added to the institutions sure
yeah this is that you don't really have
to give a trigger you can just pass it
yeah
yeah
um
yeah so we don't we we don't know how to
fight it for feedback due to the middle
of S Plus the to the end
all right
um okay there are other uh I think
interesting questions I what I didn't
with regards to automate ability but
could be discussed like what what about
if I what if I think of some subclasses
of problems can I understand
automatability there I think there are
many
um
um interesting questions that have not
been addressed yet
always smaller than two to the end right
uh yes yes what what I could do is uh I
could give it time positive
polynomialness plus poly2 to the end I
could give uh even two to the little low
of s
um
[Music]
no I mean I
if uh depending on what s is
quasi poly and S could be larger than 2
Jillian
um so yeah it's true like here it
doesn't make sense but you could think
of other
other functions here that would
um
yeah it's important it's important that
the whole the tits of the end you have
the poly but for the S you could have
events like to the middle of a mess that
we still don't know anything but do you
always want to give kids I mean you're
saying like if I get dressed up
to today's Times the question doesn't
make sense
um
maybe I'm interested in the full range
yeah so if I I do know how to answer
this question right this is the
automatability question and I'm saying
okay but what what if I give you at
least time to the end
all right so that I you can at least
output the trivial proof
now can you output anything close to
this small proof that's thank you
this this is this is exactly what makes
it match the mcsp setup right like the
trivial explicit object yeah
actually I have a question about s is it
sized in number of bits or like number
of symbols native to the proof system
because if you look at like Rahul eye
talk from yesterday it's natively like
to the S log s to Brute Force um
to Brute Force circuits because you need
to write down like where where the gates
go and the wires right like it's not
just the number of symbols is there is
there a reason that that's yes I didn't
think too much about it
um I guess it would be number of bits if
you want to actually do it into two BS
look over the interested function right
so it should be the number of bits
foreign
[Music]
a proof that the minimal is something
yeah
uh
um
so this is this is the algorithmic
version and you're at the the
deterministic materials from the
non-deterministic version
makes sense
yeah yeah
so think about it
so I already I was just going to ask is
there anything not are there any
non-trivial
algorithms for
right to do better than to the gas
um
not that I know but not even for
tree-like resolution
if I wanted from size S I don't know how
to do it in terms
so
[Music]
yeah this is the last slide so just
um
so
some obvious of the problems is to show
that it's empty hard to automate
um these proof systems which are
persistence for which we know how to
prove lower bounds and as we saw part of
showing this empty hardness required
proving some some lower bound
um so maybe it's possible to show empty
hardness for these proof systems
[Music]
um
also
uh here we don't know of any automating
algorithm can we show it or show that
it's not possible
um the same holds for cutting planes
we don't know any automating algorithm
can we show
that it's that there is that or that
it's not possible
um
let's sing for rescape
um and then there's some questions still
here about coefficients in order to
actually automate this in time into the
D
so just understanding coefficients
better there
um then there are also like other uh
tree-like proof systems like tree light
cutting planes it could be easier to
automate
um or maybe not or maybe we can show NP
hardness of automating tree-like cutting
planes we don't know
[Music]
um
and the reason is that the upper bounds
actually required this stag-like
structure the upper bound that at
serious Mueller has so
that's why also here we can only show
eth hardens
um then yes of course understanding
better weak automatability in resolution
that's it
[Applause]
more questions
just to understand the gap between this
rescue and this res law what's uh what's
the statement for res K is it like two
to the N to the minus K or yeah let me
just go back because it's
um
2015 here
yes
uh so you have a yeah you lose this
Factor okay so okay you can get it a
little bit uh more than constant but
that's not too much
yeah maybe maybe it's good to play
everything like Paris log we don't have
any lower bounds or anything
okay
hi Susanna so I'm just curious when you
mention the hack this uh alternate
Solutions I had also uh resulted around
the magazine today which was a little
bit stronger yes so is there an
inflation I can give to using yeah this
is because of expanders so we want we
need some uh
um about the degree expander from uh n
to N squared and we only know how to do
this red
um
so if you can have a better construction
of uh unbalanced unbalanced expanders
then you would get a better result
foreign